acetic acid is an example of a weak acid
and sodium hydroxide is an example of a
strong base
when acetic acid reacts with sodium
hydroxide an aqueous solution of sodium
acetate is formed along with water since
this reaction is an acid-base
neutralization reaction and these
reactions go to completion instead of
using an equilibrium arrow we simply
draw an arrow going to the right
next let's write the overall ionic
equation this is also called the
complete ionic equation let's start with
acetic acid acetic acid is a weak acid
that only partly ionizes in solution
therefore in an aqueous solution of
acetic acid
most of the acetic acid molecules stay
protonated and don't turn into acetate
therefore we're just going to write
ch3cooh down here we're not going to
show acetic acid ionizing into h plus
and the conjugate base
however things are different for sodium
hydroxide sodium hydroxide is a strong
base and strong bases dissociate 100
percent in solution so an aqueous
solution of sodium hydroxide consists of
sodium cations and hydroxide anions
next let's think about our products we
have an aqueous solution of sodium
acetate sodium acetate is a soluble salt
therefore an aqueous solution we would
have sodium cations n a plus
and the acetate anion
ch3coo minus
because water ionizes only to an
extremely small extent we don't write it
as the ions we simply write
h2o
to save some time i've added in some
aqueous subscripts and a liquid one for
water some plus signs and the reaction
arrow so this balanced equation
represents the complete ionic equation
next we're going to use the complete
ionic equation to write the net ionic
equation for this weak acid strong base
reaction and to do that we first need to
identify spectator ions remember
spectator ions don't participate in the
reaction so looking at the complete
ionic equation there are sodium cations
on the left and sodium cations on the
right so we can cross out the sodium
cation that's our spectator ion after we
take out the sodium cation what's left
over is our net ionic equation so for
our net ionic equation we have acetic
acid plus hydroxide anion forms the
acetate anion and water
now that we have our net ionic equation
we're going to think about three
different situations in the first
situation we have equal moles of our
weak acid and our strong base
looking at our balanced net ionic
equation the mole ratio of our weak acid
to our strong base is one to one
therefore if we have equal moles of our
weak acid and our strong base and the
mole ratio is one to one the weak ass
and the strong base are going to
completely neutralize each other and
form the acetate anion
so if our goal is to figure out the ph
of the resulting solution we don't need
to consider acetic acid and we don't
need to consider the hydroxide ions
because these have been completely used
up we need to think about the acetate
anion in aqueous solution and in aqueous
solution acetate anions react with water
to form acetic acid and hydroxide ions
this reaction does come to an
equilibrium and since kb is less than
one at equilibrium there will be a large
amount of reactants and only a small
amount of products however since we are
increasing the concentration of
hydroxide ions in solution the resulting
solution will be basic
therefore at 25 degrees celsius the ph
of the resulting solution will be
greater than 7. if we wanted to
calculate the actual ph we would need
some more information but we would treat
it just like a weak base equilibria
problem
also note that the hydroxide ions that
we wrote down here are not the same
thing as the hydroxide ions from our net
ionic equation the hydroxide ions from
our net ionic equation went away
completely they they were neutralized by
reacting with the acetic acid so these
hydroxide ions were generated from the
anion hydrolysis reaction of acetate
plus water and even though it's only a
small amount or a small concentration of
hydroxide ions those are the hydroxide
ions that make the ph greater than seven
for the second situation let's think
about the weak acid being in excess
since the mole ratio of our weak acid to
our strong base is one to one if we have
more of the weak acid than we do of the
strong base all the strong base will be
used up and we will form the acetate
anion and when the reaction comes to
completion there will be no more
hydroxide ion in solution
so if our goal is to find the ph of the
resulting solution we don't need to
consider the hydroxide ion at all since
it's all been used up we need to think
about the weak acid that was in excess
acetic acid and we also have to think
about the acetate anion that was formed
in the neutralization reaction
first let's think about the weak acid
that was in excess acetic acid will
react with water to form the hydronium
ion h3o plus and the acetate anion
ch3coo minus
because the concentration of hydronium
ions in solution increases that makes
the solution more acidic
therefore when the weak acid is in
excess the ph of the resulting solution
will be less than 7 at 25 degrees
celsius
if our goal is to calculate the actual
ph of the resulting solution our first
thought would be this is a weak acid
equilibria problem and it is however
there are two sources of acetate anion
one source of acetate anion is from the
reaction of acetic acid with water and
then the other source of the acetate
anion came from our acid-base
neutralization reaction therefore one
way to think about this problem is it's
actually a common ion effect problem
where the common ion is the acetate
anion the presence of a common ion
decreases the ionization of acetic acid
in water however since the concentration
of hydronium ions will still increase
the ph of the solution will be less than
seven another way to think about this
problem is when we formed the acetate
anion from the from the neutralization
reaction we had some of the weak acid in
excess and when we have a weak acid and
its conjugate base present a buffer
solution forms and so we could also use
the henderson-hasselbalch equation to
calculate the ph of the resulting
solution
for the third situation let's think
about the strong base being an excess
since the mole ratio of our weak acid to
our strong base is one to one if we have
the strong base in excess the strong
base is going to neutralize all of the
weak acid therefore when the reaction
comes to completion there will be no
more weak acid present
so if our goal is to find the ph of the
resulting solution we would just have to
think about the extra hydroxide ions in
solution and since there are extra
hydroxide ions from our strong base we
know at 25 degrees celsius the ph of the
solution will be greater than seven so
the resulting solution will be basic if
we wanted to calculate the actual ph of
the solution this would become a strong
base ph calculation problem
and while it is true that the acetate
anions that were produced from the
neutralization reaction will react with
water to also increase the concentration
of hydroxide ions the concentration of
hydroxide ions that we would get from
the anion hydrolysis of the acetate
anion would be negligible to the
hydroxide ions that were left over
therefore we could just consider the
strong base to calculate the ph and we
don't need to worry about anion
hydrolysis for this particular situation